turning now to the investigation into
the murder of gabby potito over the
weekend a memorial was held near her
childhood home here in new york potato
disappeared while on a cross-country
road trip with her fiance brian laundry
national correspondent jurica duncan has
been following this for us tarika good
morning good morning to you a lot of
people attended that memorial family
friends and those touched by gabby
potito's story mourned her loss this
weekend yesterday hundreds of people
lined up at a long island funeral home
to pay their respects to petito
some waited at least an hour delivering
the eulogy potito's father joe said he
couldn't be more proud as a father
gabby is
the most
amazing person i've ever met
so if you're going to leave here today
i'm asking that you guys be inspired by
the way she treated people
ryan laundry gabby petito's fiance was
not mentioned but potito's father said
he received emails from around the
country from people who said they were
in toxic relationships and in an
apparent reference to laundry said if
there's a relationship that you're in
that might not be the best thing for you
leave it now the manhunt for laundry
continues today after an exhaustive
search and a florida nature reserve has
so far turned up no clues the fbi though
has made an arre has an arrest warrant
for laundry yesterday they returned to
his parents home for personal items they
need for dna matching yeah zarika you've
been covering this case for us in 48
hours what else stood out to you what
else caught your eye you know the
obvious question is where is brine
laundry everyone wants to know and how
did you know we get here but what stood
out to me actually was the close
connection with the family you know the
the father the biological father made a
point to say gabby didn't have you know
two parents she had four
referencing the step parents but just
talking about the amount of love that
she had for them and that they had for
her and i mean we knew early on when we
interviewed them last week um they were
advocates as a unit all four of them so
i think to see the strength that they're
able uh to exude to get through this
really difficult time is is really uh
amazing i thought it was touching too
that the father took that time to
encourage people to get out of it yeah
relationship yes considering what his
daughter went through and many in the
family and her friends didn't seem to
know that it was as bad as it it appears
to be right what we're learning about
that and just his overall message to
live you know you don't know tomorrow's
not promise and and just
man i was so impressed by how how well
they kept it together at that memorial
service and talking about her but what
an incredible young young woman yeah
jerica thank you so much